okay
levi yes sir levi where are you from
originally orange county huntington
beach
it's orange county out here how long you
been here on skid row uh
about five six years now five six years
do you have a family uh no my mom just
passed away ten years ago and my last
known relative my uncle passed away two
years ago
so put out there i don't know it's just
me no kids no wife no tell me about your
childhood what was it like
i was good i rang my mom i raised five
six five kids on a waitress salary
they were all older than me i grew up by
myself in the house and
i'm gonna do whatever she could and i
mean i lived with my mom until
i was 14 years old and then i walked in
one day coming home from school and
my stepdad was drunk and i was in the
garage beating the [ __ ] out of my mom
well i'm gonna wait for a long time for
that one
but um yeah i've been out here for a
while
and you live here on skid row yeah where
are you hitting broadway
so you're in a tent uh cardboard
cardboard yeah you have a girlfriend
anything like that no it's just me no i
mean you and your bike
very cool bike love your bike
what's your drug of choice down here uh
spice right now spice yeah
and you've done the other ones too yeah
heroin yeah i've tried here one i'm i'm
afraid
because i'm too much of a drug addict
you know and i my hustle ain't i just
panhandle so i'm like
everyone's too expensive for me crystal
just running around the streets
going nowhere so i smoke five cheaper
than we eating
no so you make money by panhandling
recycling i recycle in the morning and
then i pan out in the afternoon
and come here and eat dinner that's it
i'm down where do you eat
usually the midnight or someone i'll be
panhandling a chicken place if someone
buy me some food yeah
but if that don't happen i'll come down
here to midnight yeah
ain't you safe at nighttime but it's
okay
so do you do you sell as well no i don't
know you don't sell um so so tell me
about sleeping here
do you sleep here at night i sleep i
used to sleep right here until um
uh somebody decided to wake me up with a
bright yellow cold by four o'clock in
the morning
oh what a bright yellow crowbar oh some
yeah some cuban dude was drunk
uh he tried to wake him up with a like
four o'clock in the morning right here
six in los angeles with the crowbar
luckily he dropped the crowbar so i was
able to get the better ham so i don't
sleep down past los angeles anymore i'm
up
towards broadway picked by rite aid and
stuff in a little doorway so the manager
is cool with me as long as i clean up my
master's tub
you've seen some crazy stuff i'm sure
yes yes
it's okay to sleep by people but then
it's not okay you know you never know
when you're gonna wake up
so i sleep next to a little 68 year old
woman right now in a wheelchair
so you know she does her things during
the day and then the next time we both
go in her little cubby hole and
i get her up put her in the chair in the
morning then she does her thing
down this way could be dangerous know
what what year you started
how old were you when you first used it
i was 13 years old
13 no what drug was that my first drug
my first drug was islamo methamphetamine
for my girlfriend
14 years old and then we and all that
have you ever been clean uh in prison
in prison yeah yeah what were we in
prison for i was in fishing for
manslaughter when i was 14 to 21 years
old and then
i've been to a federal prison for
manufacturing counterfeit securities and
explosives
wow but i've been i've been up now for
five years no prohibition on parole
nothing
what uh manslaughter tell me about that
uh
that's when i walked home and i'm 14
years old and i found my my
bad beating [ __ ] out of my my mom my mom
was unconscious she was bleeding in the
corner so
i was on my way to baseball practice so
i had my bad and i [ __ ] i hit my
stepdad 38 times in the head
just so he stopped hitting my mom and i
killed him
again you and i live from 14 to 21 years
old
that's justified
wow that's heavy
are you an only child i got two step
brothers and two step sisters but
they're they were all older than anyone
else
yeah when i was going to the house
you're basically an only child no
wow thank you for sharing that
um where do you want to see yourself in
five years
run gone
you have no hope for anything brighter
or
no i don't know
it's about another day you know yeah
it's hard here
thank you for talking with me luck with
everything
thank you
you